the Joe Rogan experience oh yeah I see I
you know I get a lot of I got a lot of
[ __ ] for this and I talked about a
little bit on on my podcast but you know
I was in the room but Trump a lot you
know I did two tours yeah I did two
tours of duty tell me about that what is
that like I was supposed to do that show
and I passed on it yeah I was like I
don't want to live in New York for three
months or whatever it was yeah just
seemed like a it's wise either way it
was a it was a prime-time television
show so it's sold tickets and that is
our job
right and that's what we do and I went
on with one idea in my head you know
Annie Duke you know the poker player she
had been on the year before and I said
why am I going on I mean I'm normal sell
tickets and that's that's just a done
deal but why am I going on what's my
wheel goal and she said go on and show
that atheist can be kind that'll be your
only goal for the whole show because
they're gonna jump on you for being
atheist they'll jump all over you for
that and just show that you're the one
that gets mad the least so the one that
you're the nicest guy on there and
you're the hardcore atheist and I went
okay that's a good goal but then you sit
in the room and I don't know how well
you know the president United States and
I don't want to know them at all yeah
but you spend about two or three hours
every other day sitting in a room across
the table like this with a table you
can't put your hands on I can't because
it might Mar it in other that's
hilarious but a hand promote they
literally tell you don't put your hands
at the end of the table and you have to
sit up straight and the camera if you're
like the team captain which by the way
they hate it if you call them team
captain I'd like to have it you know sub
sort of business jargon and you're in
you're in a set and that's the thing
that everybody else on the show would
say we're going into the boardroom now
and I'd say no we're going on to the
boardroom set so it wasn't a real
boardroom no of course not not a sound
stage it was you know it was in the
Trump Towers but they've taken over if
Lauren MVC guts it and puts up this [ __ ]
and then I bet your camera that your
hero camera that's over your shoulder
that's shooting Trump so you can't leave
into the camera Brian and they want a
little piece you can't lean out of the
camera so that you've gotten about two
hours where you sit up straight and you
can't move side to side and it can't put
your hands at the table and you listen
to someone speak for two hours that
they're gonna try to edit out to get
three minutes where he sounds okay okay
what does he have to say for two hours
he will talk he would talk I mean things
obviously have changed but he would talk
about I was reading this blog on the
internet that said I didn't sell my
property for enough and I bought it for
three million dollars and I sold it for
four million isn't that a profit isn't
that a profit what do you think isn't
that a profit yeah that would be a
million dollars profit well they said I
sold it for two less they too little
okay who was this there's somebody on
the Internet
okay so you know he'd be arguing in
front of us with perhaps a 18 year old
guy on the internet who thought that
Donald Trump should have made more from
a real estate deal and this is something
he really concentrates on he seems to
still to this day yeah obsessed with
what anybody says about him anytime
that's so hot and I thought and I want
to say this very clearly um I thought he
was wonderful at his job you know if you
had someone who was actually a business
person on that show it would be the
worst show in the world because Bill
Gates would make proper decisions and
there'd be no surprises
you want someone capricious and crazy
with no filter that's what you want
right and that's what we got so he makes
arbitrary decisions that you try you
know the human brain tries desperately
to make those make sense and that ends
up being some kind of entertainment and
so I actually actually a Donald Trump
jr. said to me you know if all the
people we've had on the show you seem
like the only person who's ever liked my
father he said you actually seem to like
them and I said you know I have a
fascination and a respect and a
affection for people who are
able to get out of their filters and I
said some people do that with pure
genius like Bob Dylan some people do it
with bravery like Lenny Bruce some
people do it with drugs you know Neil
Young perhaps Jimi Hendrix perhaps and
most people do it with a mixture of
stuff but I said felonious monk said the
genius is the one who is most like
himself and I said with some sort of
mental problems
coupled with greed and a lack of
compassion
your father has somehow found a way to
throw off the filters and I will listen
to Tiny Tim talk on tape for hours
because I like that little bit of
Asperger's and all that other stuff I'm
I'm not assuming I'm not qualified but
I'm saying this oddity yes I can hear
him talk forever I can listen to Lenny
Bruce you know how well there has those
hundreds hours of him just ranting under
his tape I think I don't like people on
drugs that much but boy I do and I
listen to Lenny Bruce talk forever and
Donald Trump had the dark side of that
you know it's almost like when I was
hitchhiking around the country and you
know homeless and [ __ ] and you'd end up
in a biker place and you know some
Clubhouse and some guys just holding
court ranting I've always been
interested in the people who were out on
the margins you know and what what
Donald Jr took as affection like I guess
was a bit of affection but it's also
that if you have thrown off some filters
I'll listen to you talk and so that was
that it was very very strange and then I
really did spend a lot of time kind of
sticking up for Donald Trump saying yeah
there's interesting stuff there and yeah
he's crazy and he's venal and he's empty
you know really weird stuff that you've
never seen before
you have never seen someone who has
never laughed sincerely and never made a
joke
never laugh sincerely no evil he will
laugh in a bully way haha look at a fat
Joe really yeah he'll do that but he
won't laugh at himself Oh No
and also but never a even a joke even it
says there are only things on Twitter
did you see the thing he did on Twitter
the other day where you put a picture of
Trump Tower in Greenland and he said I
promised not to do this yeah yeah I mean
I laughed
mmm that was funny hmm a giant Trump
Tower in the middle of Greenland I never
saw it I mean I saw that but we never
saw him in person I never saw the person
I also never saw him showing the
enjoyment or understanding of music ah
and those two things are two things that
I connect with people very much on